P Rockstar 34 with this one missed my
flight by two minutes so now I'm in the
back of the car and I have to drive five
and a half six hours to Charleston and
it's already midnight or it's my actions
not midnight that's good I'll get a
little sleep but it's 950 and I got to
be onstage at 9 o'clock in the morning
what six hours of driving because I
missed my connecting flight by 120
seconds you know
the glamorous life of an entrepreneur
so I'll champagne bottles and models the
big life houses and cars and watches
right my ass earning are you doing
super duper well at an awesome meal last
night I missed my connecting flight and
drove five and half hours from Atlanta
to Charleston and got here at 5:00 a.m.
and drank some [ __ ] coffee in my
hotel and ready to rock and roll this
morning
ready to go it's almost like when rap
got big like everybody just decided
they're gonna be a rapper like you can't
just decide you're gonna be an
entrepreneur you can there's a big
difference between being an entrepreneur
and having entrepreneurial tendencies
and actually being a successful
entrepreneur and I think a lot of people
have been extending their college lives
and disguising it as entrepreneurship
and are losing a lot of people's eye
I worked [ __ ] hard for my money I
came here with zero I didn't have a
single [ __ ] vacation day or weekend
since I was in the seventh grade
I'm not pumped about losing my money
right I'm not a VC like everybody else
where I made money on the carry and
because I went to Yale and then beta
McKinsey and I grew up in the lead
environment so I was able to start a
venture firm when I lose money it hurts
me hard a you know hundred thousand
dollars is more money than my [ __ ]
dad made for the first ten years he was
in America like this isn't a joke to me
so no I do not feel bad for the
businesses on the other side and I'm
really looking forward to dead [ __ ]
carnage and complete fighters and death
in this space so that we can recalibrate
what the [ __ ] we're talking about
because the audacity to think that
something bad happened to the business
person in an environment where they took
normal people's money who are gonna get
all pumped up about the JOBS Act because
CNN and Fox are gonna have to talk about
something after the [ __ ] presidential
election and everybody's gonna find
their [ __ ] sucks and Travis and
you're gonna put in $5,000
website and it's going to be the next
book at Facebook and they're gonna make
seven point eight million dollars it's
going to be [ __ ] terrible yes no no
and I'm gonna tell you why no because if
24 year old me was sitting up there
here's what would be happening
[ __ ] this old dude I'm gonna [ __ ]
navigate build a big [ __ ] business
and I can't wait to email this [ __ ]
in ten years and be like yelled I was in
Charleston when you're reduce dating I
just build one hundred million dollar
business [ __ ] cuz that does that too
that is what an entrepreneur is they
don't care what your mom thinks your
friends thinks that it's cool if it's
not they can't breathe they have to
build their thing and they have the
confidence regardless of somebody before
them says it's going to be good and bad
because a real entrepreneur can actually
navigate through the toughest times
that's when the best businesses are
built a lot of the great companies that
we talk about now they were not Amazon
and eBay were navigating through the
[ __ ] right and they've navigated well to
build great companies I'm proud that I
built Wine Library when it was
completely Wall Street centric high-end
wine during a collapse on Wall Street
and 9/11 it was very hard how I don't
Wine Library and vaynermedia was built
in 2009 and 10 when [ __ ] was bad so if
they're so good if you're so great if
you're so gonna be the person I have
great news for you shits about to get
bad and you get to prove it thank you
Thank You Kari he want to crush it line
rush said my name is Peter Kafka I'm
senior editor at recode I cover media
and technology and I've been doing some
version of this for more than a decade
in 2007 I was the first hire what was a
company called Silicon Alley insider at
the idea originally was were going to
cover a lot of New York tech businesses
that ended up pivoting into a bigger
focus but for a while anyone who did
anything in New York and anything new
the internet 2007 we would be interested
in and it was a pretty small group of
people David Karp founded this little
logging thing called tumblr we were all
interested in Twitter because it kind of
seemed like a New York company even
though it's based out west then one of
the guys was Gary Vee who was this guy
who turned this wine business into an
online wine business and was becoming an
online celebrity was a very new novel
thing so we were all interested in what
Gary was doing kind of seemed like a
novelty at the time a lot of folks
probably myself included figured alright
this is a novelty he's going to move on
into something else so it's pretty
impressive that nearly 10 years later
there's now an entire Gary Vee industry
good job Gary it's good to see you again
hi Margaret Margaret how are you good
I'm gonna put you garyun let's go left
okay
ladder for me it is right what are you a
lot a lot because of that man Yeah right
there mica good yep they go Bert can you
humming there's that one coming out from
this was this one's d-roc yours
I want the streets to love me I want
that trenches to love me which is why
I'm attracted to the south and female
entrepreneurs and minorities and so I
tell them every time consistently and I
don't like saying it as a white dude
that made it in America but I but it's
true which is if anybody has ever made
it that looks like you then you can too
and what's harder much harder than
getting money or respect from the
establishment is actually winning with
the market when when somebody will say
to me well Gary I can't get funding
because I'm a girl or I can't get
funding because I'm from Mexico I go bro
it's when bro its way harder to actually
have your product win with
summers than to get some old white dudes
on Sand Hill Road to write you a check
so if this is breaking you down if
you're crying now you're in deep [ __ ]
[ __ ] the markets the ultimate validation
the market makes old white dudes that
are racists seem soft last question like
that I like that yeah like that directly
sure that's an aggression Gary van but
do you understand I do like if you're
crumbled by what the media or what VCS
are giving you an at-bat you have no
shot in the reality of the marketplace
right because you make it work they're
gonna follow you if you've got the idea
you've got track and you're making
revenue they're coming to you of course
they don't care that's what's so great
about capitalism capitalism could be so
[ __ ] up but the second you have the
leverage of success they'll be the first
in line to say they're sorry and write
you a big fat check we love you and
you're always welcome
thank you brother thanks Gary that was
interesting this is a salty salty day
salty V is in full effect again are you
sir good to meet you nice to me kid yeah
how are you I'm great right all right so
what are we doing yeah what we're gonna
do today is we're gonna freeze Gary the
action oh this is snapchat you have ten
seconds go okay and then we're gonna do
a light painting by how could you like
30 seconds right then I'm we're gonna
continue and then what and then we are
gonna use a LED light 200 little LED
lights in the background and paint a big
geometric pattern and a 30-second
exposure BAM boom all right you're gonna
be response cuz we got right there yep
and um you're gonna a flash is gonna go
on and then you have to be a statue for
about 30 seconds oh [ __ ] okay wait wait
you want me to stand still for 30
seconds right a little this this might
be the greatest challenge of my career
you gonna literally said hey you have to
need to become a Navy SEAL in two hours
go and save this hostage and I'd be like
okay that's more doable than what I need
to do right now but I'm gonna try T
Rexes look wild
and rock and roll 1 2 3
I know you think I'm crazy but you're
super tack sharp all this motion in
front of you are the LED light look
their stuff going on down here
that's really neat can I do a selfie
yeah of course
awesome hey guys do same actually yeah
pretty cool awesome thank you thank you
so much thanks for having me
oh we love thank you grandmother's for
the book signing
well since gorgeous awesome how are you
so better than last year inside the know
my god last for this first tweet I see
no one New York gives a [ __ ] about
Charleston
boy it's so it's so interesting they
like how it like I you guys really like
it's not where I'm not coming from a bad
place come from a good place
hi guys hello so so far pretty good day
a lot of good stuff reiki rock what was
interesting
yeah the market is the market it's a
really good story like you know I think
a good title for this one might be if
anybody ever made it that looks like you
you can too right I've been saying that
a lot or something to that degree I
really believe in that like I love how
people are more scared in the pre-market
than the actual market they're more
worried about why nobody will give them
money and how hard they have it as
someone who's a minority or or a saw a
small segmentation and there are so many
examples of it race or gender but
there's also like I'm from the south and
I can't the market is way tougher than
the white dude VC establishment and we
need to start recognizing that if you're
crying that you can't raise money then
the markets going to eat you up real
quick and so the other thing is you
should take that as an advantage to
actually build a business that isn't
predicated on raising money this is your
opportunity to go in a different
direction build a tangible business that
makes money there's a lot of places to
get money from you don't just need them
from venture capitalists you can get
them from so many other places and so
yeah that's what I think generation of
course it's awesome cool man
hey do you rock you enjoy man yeah get
in here D Rock it's good let's get you
in a middle man yeah P rock in the
middle so egotistical do you rap okay
yes I do
I don't know how if you can make it out
but that's what I do so check this
wasn't in my soundcloud page for my
music production and everything but I
want to just to ask you like yeah doing
everything with social media yes hit up
all those small blogs yes like I know
like Nick wari know and all those yes
I'm just curious if you know like any
other methods that I can kind of mark
get awareness right on the start cuz
it's hard I think I think Twitter
searches killer yeah yeah the kind of
music you're making you know the terms
it's like I know about wine or the Jets
like I know how to put I'll give you a
good example in jet talk because that I
think I'll give you what if you search
Malden on Twitter you're gonna get a
duper jet ban then you're gonna get if
you search Brandon Marshall got it yeah
so what you need to do on Twitter is
search those kind of terms yeah
and then literally just engage with
somebody be like yeah I love uh I love
his work or her work and they like who's
this guy that likes it then I'm gonna
look at your Twitter account your
SoundCloud is gonna be linked got it it
is the number one way when you're at
zero to win yeah take two spend five
hours a day [ __ ] just jamming yeah
with people that have like interests
they become aware of you because you
talked about things that you both like
search hashtags on Instagram yeah hook
so somebody puts out a some love to an
artist that does similar stuff you leave
a comment it's the only person to
comment something like yeah her [ __ ] is
rad
and they're like who's this dude yeah
they click it cool they click your lick
got it yeah that's a hundred percent
what you should do sweet and you by the
way you should start doing that now yeah
all right everything together how much
do I have two minutes for this guy yeah
okay let's do it
alright so I love you better see you
around miss your dad tonight yeah
actually you know what that's a sick a
photo for your dad love it
to be well good CA so my name is
Fernando this is a more sustained
creativity's do you know idea Trey love
it and you seem to be a digital idea
master what do you think about it I
think I'm a master yes all right so I'm
over here and can you tell us a little
bit about your book um yes sure I I
wrote a book on the state of the union
of being an entrepreneur and a digital
social internet marketing a guy people
get confused about the value of content
versus the value of context I'm not
gonna say very many things for the rest
of my life I've got four to six basic
things I believe in I'm just very very
good at making a contextual for the day
that we live in every single day the end
and that's what I would tell you to do
right I can write this book every year I
can write this book every day every year
the rest of my life because it but it's
all in its religion and its religion
it's going to be the same yes but in its
tactics it will be different it's
because I want to affect the youth with
at least I don't want them to think like
me I don't want them to idolize me I
just want them to hear me to use my
message against what they hear from
other people because I think I'm in the
minority of selling hard work in a world
where everybody wants it now and I just
want them to have my voice in her ear
along with all the tricks and the
secrets and the systems that I think
they're getting pounded with on
Instagram and other places well that's
great that's great advice I'm sorry I
know no worries if this is not too much
to ask please in a couple of course I'm
still gonna Matt no worries animals
Gary yes no wrong he said hide my
snapchat family side of the youtubes yes
I love you too baby right I'm gonna do
that second six ten seconds of advice
don't listen to anybody about your mama
not this guy not me just listen to your
heart do whatever you want
there it is it's
more feet you guys grew up with all this
stuff like I'm old what we didn't have
YouTube or the internet to like do
practical things around what you love
and you can and that's serious it's
funny the theme that's breaking out in
today's episode is the market is the
market is the market and it's ironic
that it's happening on one of my
favourite leisure days I mean literally
spending a boatload of money like you
guys all talk to me about like why don't
you fly private because I never want to
spend the money in a business context
sometimes I keep it frugal but because
the NFL Draft is one of my favorite days
a year I'm flying because I need to get
to a Jay's house in time for it that's
how much it matters to me and it's funny
this whole market is the market is the
market thing it's so real so I look at
NFL players that are NFL ready first
rounders today they've been analyzed by
all these Scouts and all these pundits
right and people are judging where they
should be taken in the 32 picks of the
first round no different than a bunch of
VCS analyzing businesses and and one of
the themes that have been coming up is
I'm trying to tell people like look you
know if you think it's hard being a
minority or from a small town or a
female entrepreneur and nobody's giving
me money and you're crying about that
and you don't realize that that is much
easier than what you're going to deal
with when your product actually goes to
the market and the market takes over and
decides then you're not a winning player
in the same way that today 32 guys are
gonna get drafted to the NFL clearly
this quarterback that's gonna be taken
number one and two there could be
another quarterback or two taking the
first round all the pundits all the
experts all the analysis is saying these
are the two best but then the market
takes over then these four guys or three
quarterbacks that get taken today have
to actually go on the field and they
have to play and then no matter what
everybody said Oh Bill Polian 14 years
of NFL experience if he's wrong because
he judged you without knowing what
happens when you hit the market you get
to stick it to him or he's right that's
the bottom line at the end of the day
all the talking all the challenges
beforehand all the kids that came from
small towns without a dad
our learner parents got killed in a car
accident or whatever it may be that are
now made it to this point no matter what
it was or the private school kid on the
offensive line that came from a rich
family
and had an easy way write to Michigan
University in the play it doesn't matter
how you got there now you got to this
moment then you get picked the market
says you're the 18th best player but you
can be the first wrestler if we
redrafted bond Miller's draft I bet you
could draft an earlier right I don't
think Tom Brady slips to the sixth round
of the NFL Draft then tells me to say
that I don't think Tom I don't think
Russell Wilson I'll go there makes me
feel better
nothing Russell Wilson goes in the third
round of the NFL Draft if we do it today
but that's because it hit the market and
so what I'm imploring entrepreneurs to
do is to not cry about all the reasons
they haven't been able to raise money in
a world where that is not the market
that's the micro market the actual
market is when your business sees earth
and has to win or lose the amount of
overhyped businesses because of the
pedigree of the founders or the idea
that have happened over the last decade
that have failed is enormous and all of
the business that nobody thought would
succeed have it's just the way that's by
the way guys I yearn for this but you
know I preach what I live you know
exciting was for me to go into the
agency world on Madison Avenue where all
these big agencies existed and
everybody's like the wine guy who has a
couple of followers on Twitter thinks
he's gonna start a social media shop
which we don't even know what social
media is is it's crazy it's crazy to me
how delicious all that negativity was
and now sticking it right in their mouth
over and over and over again as I build
one of the biggest shops is so exciting
for me you know easy it was for me to
just
like just how insanely easy it would
have been for me to just be an investor
in 2010 just have a fund and just you
know easy investing life is it is yeah
yeah you're right now look you have to
be unbelievable to get to that moment in
your life yes you'd have to find the 14
then you would have personally been at a
four-year vacation when you're going to
paid a lot of money to do nothing
you know the economics where you get 2%
of the carrier you reach 50 million
dollars you know and you're getting a
million dollars a year and you have
200,000 expenses printed out
but like but like you know crusher you
make $800,000 here to meet people and
give them money number two if you don't
win it's been stunning to me how many
people can go out and raise money from
the next year maybe you can't get it for
the best people yeah
doing I guess the reason the reason I
just said to you like the reason I just
said that to you is like I don't I get
mad when people don't realize how much
of my own dog food I actually eat like
like well I'm like go work go work like
build a business that's what I've done
the last six seven years like on this
plumber I wouldn't build a business a
meaningful business and I did during
good times when it was it's actually
harder to build a big business and a
good business when it's easy to not have
to the next decade is gonna be about
building actual businesses again so
interesting
and so interesting because when
everybody's gonna be forced the next
decade to build businesses I'm gonna be
investing
because they're gonna be under Prime
it's unbelievable how a counter it's
unbelievable how countercultural I am in
all aspects like
I have to be for me I'm so
anti-establishment I so dudes things
that are not scalable I so when things
are too good I go the other way I make
it harder on myself
I'm gonna make a lot of money my 50s and
60s a lot noted by the Jets I see the
pattern recognition out where I didn't
at 30 when I looked myself in the mirror
where I don't have the wealth that even
makes it even conceivable for me to do
that now I see the patterns I've learned
I've learned 30 to 40 what I needed I'm
feel very accomplished
it's forget about the money or the I'm
gonna make a lot of 1452 but like like
it's gonna be really interesting I see
it very clearly I like it and so I don't
know I think I've said it before like
people crying or complaining is the
quickest tell on a non winning player
the entrepreneur tells me how hard it is
to be raising money and how unfair the
market is and how they need your money
to help Gary cuz everybody and losing
mentality doesn't make me feel very good
about how they're gonna succeed when
they don't get enough downloads or when
they don't keep enough customers or when
their marketing didn't work or when the
right-hand man quits on them or when
some company copies the copy my hack
put your head down and execute
everything else will work itself out
it's incredible
boys are a lot of stuff I can't have
pretty angle I don't want looking for
the angle I know I do that tool is the
all-time but usually mine's more like
Nate's coming over an hour
hey Enzo hey buddy
yes I'll be right back
rere
she take back Center City Tory goes
wonder what he's any wonder look stupid
come on Gary I'm not gonna be okay I
don't want to know that just wanted to
make sure you're still in the room oh
you were in the room before the bed all
night last is Patrick crazy Teddy would
rather not talk yeah yeah that's right
Nate she's electric first a snapchat
you're sitting there go we're not gonna
run no sources negotiators creating love
I look at that sour cherry haven't seen
their now the not only which is no
complaining couple say okay jesters are
smart now give me those other options I
think we have common talk about the old
done it ain't got a fits deal pretty
much I don't think I think like I said I
don't worry about fits if I don't get
like he might want logs on one or two
good McDonald Accord invest yeah that's
a [ __ ] to over also he's off at 7 to 8
million dollar who's a good employee
yeah this is it I give imports that he's
doing well I I laugh out loud
but now is happening this be responsible
for feedback and I find laughing I laugh
like I'm like this I feel like they're
joking nothing no I know
AJ please you see this you're gonna [ __ ]
when you're about to hear what happened
comfortable but but it is about a have
yes soup I is that no that's true by the
way Oh once with a video of him just
smoking not out of a gas mask around a
calendar like literally absolutely 10
minutes ago
you know this is keeping trauma first
rapid right now how do they know it's
him watch click watch Lillian it takes
it off at the NDSU but what's wrong with
that
that's what's wrong today
you see what snapchat did right
I can't believe they got all that we got
a line for you as a cash Roger this past
year the workers two years ago people
can see they are 12 feet obviously every
net just in general a nurse for food
most gladly mentally proximal to the
Tennessee Titans black 38 fit back in
the 2016 NFL Draft
the Tennessee Titans select Jack Conklin
Wow now I buy it we see now I'm fine
who's like oh you're Twitter you know
what I'm all-in I'm Gruden to put away
your Twitter right beseech me to that
let me tweet this miles Carbonite
extract the honey wait leave me see this
little arrow flow and Rajesh during the
robbery
with the 20th pick in the 2016 NFL verse
effects at PacSun the New York Jets
which daringly potentially people say
well ionize six-foot breakwaters you
sketch it for the first round we have
not taken off its players first-round
just good day
good day
got a new jet also a lot
sponge
good day welcome to new Chet and family
I got there uh have to spend some
quality time good time be SBI just play